[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors sacha elbaz ayami encore si chaud
sur la pente oui et moi aussi j'ai aucun
des tunisiens
racontent et c au sol car ils sont plus
grands que l'entente
avec l'as d'or du 45 sort du championnat
tu prends des chaussures grande fête
croit qu'il va encore grandir du pied
là-bas je suis pas fait pas très gros je
suis très grande mais vous aimez pas
mais tu sens sans nul doute je suis
combien je chausse du 43 44 frère cadet
s'est pas dit non à mon avis je vous
jure qu'en dieu t'a fait il avait fini
répéta j'oubliais
il a demandé à ses généraux mais moi les
abdos quelqu'un apporte qui va aller on
mettra ça mettait sur son cas devant les
îles c'est un peu pour 10,3 bordeaux
d'abord
la maison et a mis les pieds de david
douillet
et le gall fermé demain avec 50 70 80
comme je suis en tunisie m a tout mis en
bas dans les anges dans les cuisses dans
l'autre je t'ai vu alors c'est pas vrai
et un très beau corps je t'ai vu sur la
plage ttout annonce ici j'ai vu des
photos sur la plage parce que les c'est
l'été je me faisais de la pastèque mais
là je ne veux pas que saint patrick est
du coup ces gros potentiel et gérard
morel juste après après
non mais j'ai les bouées à mon âge c'est
pas normal bon bah tu nous racontes raté
ses débuts comme chaque semaine on
commence avec un peu de retard ça va il
est vraiment parti complètement
j'ai croisé
sans déconner on dirait un gars qui
vient des tripes notizai ou une
tentative
il en descend dit
alors que
rossi est j'ai fait une micro-sieste ait
été fait il ya
[Musique]
des gros gros soucis de santé
la santé mentale c'est aussi la santé
[Rires]
la santé c'est mon problème ça va très
bien et vous voulez en parler strass une
période compliquée qu'est ce que tu as
joué au plus mal
qu'est ce que tu as je passais bien ap
est un coup
on voit très bien et j'ai battu en
dépression a bien droite en dépression a
pas je dis je n'arrête pas d'appeler
pernikoff tous les matins ça me gêne
aussi tombé en dépression d'après sans
permis bah oui
mais c'est vrai que c'est comme si j'ai
pas non mais sans déconner est un
foutoir et les anti déprime l'amour le
boulot à la finale à vicoigne la vie en
général
ici tu séguillon savez amis devant la
table c'est que c'est vrai wen touche
mais on est là on est là moi ça n'en
avait pas l'air malheureux dimanche
dernier c'est dans le 8e arrondissement
de paris en train de draguer des petites
filles dans l'une et petites filles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
deuxième
faute technique
n'est pas des petites filles jeune femme
rita gueule
[Rires]
sans déconner avec des groupes ils
ont décollé bien là avec ces grands
patins ils nous emmerdent
[Rires]
commence tout de suite avec c'est le
alona from washington
il a tous les talents se compose états
unis regarder les débats de primaire qui
avait john steinbeck mais comment voulez
y arriver savez les soins de force mais
s'ils ont des si on découvre pas
que ces foutus de ma gueule
[Rires]
et on continue avec raymond était
attendu le mois de mars pour être lucide
raymond tu es de retour soit il n'était
pas là hier mais c'est pas dire alors
moi je t'avais plan cette année mais
j'ai eu un cru au début de l'émission et
à la fin
c'est sa came here des sacs mrd way et
j'ai été bon pendant les pubs par contre
m
après les fumeurs et les vues montagne
découvrez la nouvelle vue qui va faire
fureur cdt melloussa ces abuseurs charte
abattre et après on va t'amuser nombreux
dans ma tête je bats pas assumer prend
un peu de cette rappeuse en concurrence
beach
[Applaudissements]
jma des émissions comme la
balade sans déconner la surface la
katusha
sur l'avis d'un chameau bertrand des
gears il est devenu un tube sans avis
mammeri vient de la goulette fusil donc
la reine elizabeth ii né planète
et la princesse charlene non plus n'est
plus fera là
les amis je crois que depuis que tout
est revenu gilbert 2 est complètement
pété les plombs c'est pas parc
d'attractions c'est pas la fête foraine
ne méprisez pas les fêtes font est
encore vendu près que ces données nous
sépare
c'est pas là
et près de classe mais prix nobel ne
sied pas à fait anodin
c'est parfait
si vous cherchez une technique de drague
l'écouté ba ba du couple arrive en boîte
une phrase toute faite tarifs 6 mois
faute nous fait le coup non
je rappelle pour ceux qui me regardent
avec modération
c'est là notre beau c'est nelson et là
mon avis il a kiffé sont à lille je ne
permets pas respecté les galaxies
suicide comme ça
ici
[Applaudissements]
ces revenus qui fait sans serif quelles
relations entretenez-vous avec matthieu
delormeau avancement votre bonne très
bonne un cabanon soit ont très bien
ouais
bah oui très bonne non j'ai rien à dire
c'est uniquement du travail a bien sûr
ah oui c'est sûr ça on n'a jamais su
parce que on a regardé l'émission ces
dernières semaines on a l'impression que
plus le temps passe plus on se rapproche
d'une relation papa dans papa alors il
n'était bien que moi je n'ai jamais
changé
avec eux plutôt un poste avec moi tu
t'envoles luneray chaumont point
d'entrée l'emploi
[Rires]
dis-moi rapport au besoin avec l semaine
à mykonos et
vengeance et j'y serai
ferais-tu regret qu
il espère dans les anus
ben ouais ça c'est quoi ce qui était une
belle dédicace et ses rives j'ai une
troisième balle mais dans mon slip
ou moi ce débat est bien sûr je tout le
débat risque de rencontres de cul ça se
passe à marie et pas comme ça mais je
cherche une relation sérieuse ouais bon
bah écoute désolé moi c'est pour un plan
cul tu vas tu habites hockey qui alors
bah voilà aller où la relation sérieuse
et
[Musique]
[Rires]
le cheval
ah ouais ouais
mathieu simon choisi est tatoué quelque
chose ça fait quoi où ça bouge alors
juste là moi j'aime bien ça c'est très
sexy ici
[Musique]
un beau projet de tatouages que vous
avez la belgique une question oui
peut-être qu'on couche ensemble
[Rires]
il a été réalisé
après je voulais assumer leur
maison-mère de panache
maintenant mes soeurs et benjamins i les
idées non non non non pas du maïs et
benjamin il a dit c'est bon dans la cua
ça non mais ça c'est bon tu es petit tu
sais que tu aimes bien mathieu il avait
déjà mi temps durant que nous y
arrivions de la fiq a franchement qui
dit ça
je peux dire qu ils sont par le mail mot
allah mais pour le coup lui lui le fait
que c'est possible tout le monde le sait
c'est juste que oui j'ai passé un ami
sesia pas daigné pas de séduction avec
lui quoi pourquoi nos missions
impossibles mais parce que je parte on
sait pas comment vous dire vous pensez
vous les hétéros enfin patois mais vous
pensez les hétéros que deux bd qui se
rend compte forcer l'arrêt couchent
ensemble banon là il égaye chier j'ai
pas
[Rires]
c'est pas des lego
tu as raison c'est un truc à part
l'argent qu'est-ce que cyril a que
benjamin n'a pas l'argent résidentes ou
quoi la beauté accary puissant il est
rassurant on a envie d'aller à ses bras
on sent que rien ne peut nous arriver
c'est vrai
[Rires]
la compagnie s'il a des dettes il n'est
pas rassurant non
si vous étiez de l'autre côté de la
barrière merci
à sa très bonne question pas si en tous
les cas si dans le monde du site si vous
deviez choisir quelqu'un banon mais
système est bâti sa vie va penser au
passé à ses juges si vous deviez
l'esprit jdl jdn pour moi il n'a pas
aussi s'il voit le public et des si tu
ne joues pas publics et ont convoqué
tout l'imaginaire s'est développée pour
nous et voilà pourquoi c'est vous qui me
disent qu'on sait laquelle
chabal pas de coucher je te dis juste si
lequel aurait le plus ton goût voilà
vers quoi ton avis on va pas faire
adhérer
un trade poursuite fois non mais ils
sont alors je vous dis rien mais poser
une question maintenant les gens voilà
est-ce que c'est quoi ces histoires je
galope ski podcast si vous deviez faire
l'amour avec la gare sont là des
chroniqueurs autour de la table via si
t'as pas le choix
le jour mais non raison il veut pas à
l'amiable mais ça veut pas dire que tu
vas tu choisirais tu va coucher avec sa
fille jade est bombardé
[Rires]
on a fait ce que tu aurais vous auriez
pardon mais
je vais y aller doucement linehan
panique
comme ça pour toi brad pitt est plus
beau que tom cruise automne un des plus
beaux bras j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
doucement sur les bras un je m'en fous
que j'ai même pas regardé esthétiquement
quand même vous avez un avis sur le
territoire où kate a un esthète du pied
mais les belges n'y a pas de situation
les six n'aime pas les
[Rires]
récents
événements par exemple à mathieu mathieu
des huitièmes les hommes et si jamais tu
devais coucher avec moi l'art de la
table de massage
ou de le dire lausanne ont honoré alors
isabelle pour l'une est l'affiché des
jolies femmes défini magnétique mais moi
frangy moi dans mon style c'est
géraldine oui parce qu'il ya ya ya les
belles et chic elle est lancée elle
interac plaisir
mais
est-ce que du coup il est mort omar sy
également
chéri mais chiron va se retrouver
mais de toutes les vannes on joue en
fait pour résumer ni de signes de siph
allait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
commencer avec des sifflets dans le gave
et d'orgueil c'est fou ça mais non mais
je vous dis parce que je me suis jamais
posé la question et là moi je veux la
poste avec la dre mais moi je vous la
pose pas il sait déjà qu'il me faut du
rendement des fonds morgan
avait arrêté avec cet arrêté n'était
droite le contrat parce qu'ils passent
avec ton meilleur pas dans la motié
alors je peux
alors scellé la prochaine séquence les
ce que j'aurais fait de rigoler parce
que ça risque d'engendrer un
licenciement oui je te demande que ça
là je voulais tracy lité parce que cyril
depuis trois semaines je mène l'enquêté
avec l'anc l enquête l enquête avec
sarah votre assistante ta puisque
figurez vous qu'un chroniqueur vous
spolie en chroniqueur vous vole un
chroniqueur vient dans votre bureau pour
vous dérober des effets personnels mais
les pas de bureau n'a pas de bureau et
son lancement très bien juste une éviter
de me poser
un masque à gaz j'ai pris un coup du
noël
la fontaine de trevi amène le met une
petite maï maï et l'allier jean vincent
des collèges et la mamie
donner ce singe et la mamie alors que
dans l'autre sens si on aurait valu l'or
parfois un peu sur le hockey
alors il en chroniqueur vient de fait
les saunas voulait pas d'elle
je ne garde pas des dîners c'est la
vôtre avec qu'il s'agit qui vient dans
votre bureau pour vous spolier
sait jamais si jamais non sérieux ce
chroniqueur c'est guillaume genton non
regardez
[Musique]
regardez guillaume genton qui errent
dans les couloirs d'âge de saut vers où
se dirige t il haut et cyril dans votre
bureau alors que pourtant personne n'a
droit d'y entrer c'est le bunker de
bolbec alors il ya un mois sont cyril
que vous adorez allé m'excuser votre
mini frigo en est rempli personne n'a le
droit de les prendre sauf monsieur
genton regarder et s'en octroie le droit
et ça c'est honteux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ce n'est pas fini on appelle la police
qui vous fait dire que c'est moi sur ces
images
[Rires]
vous avoir parlé oui alors pour
l'instant le larcin ce ne vaut pas
grand-chose à 6,2 euros mais c'est
important pour vous votre hibiscus mais
attendez
fatalement vers la prochaine voiture
avec ap
alors les frères t'envoie débat vous
aimez toi but envoie des grêlons mais
nancéen jacques braut alcoolique un truc
de ouf ça mais connaît c'est pas
possible un jacuzzi dans la bouche ou
quoi non me lasse pas dans la bouche des
ya des gars qui sont avec des bandes
annonces avec de foot gala doit débats
et des trucs comme ça quoi alors maison
il faut mettre des essuie glaces à
prochaine j'aime bien j'aime bien ce que
vous m'impressionnez ans a appris à ne
jamais
céder l'on vous a volé guillaume genton
a fait pire que ça regardait pas oui
encore plus grave c'est lille une
semaine plus tard alors qu'il discutait
avec le directeur adjoint et hypnotisé
en chef de votre société fabrice conca
puis j'entends a récidivé devant
guillaume genton est entré dans votre
bureau il ne va pas quand même faire ça
il ne vas pas me piquer vos fringues
surtout pas cette veste cette magnifique
veste que vous qui faites en une veste
aux coûts exorbitants que vous avez mis
six mois à acheter non il ne va pas osé
non pas ça guillaud après tout ça
[Applaudissements]
je disais je me sens pas concerné c'est
pas moi beaucoup chine et ça c'est très
grave c'est pas parce que tu fais que je
lis ce n'est pas mon rasoir tous les
deux mais si encore sa cellule alors la
veste c'est pas moi je vais faire à mes
d'accord je vais faire a mené par vos
équipes cyril en cortège avec les flics
animal social la facture s'élève
maintenant entre l'hibiscus et la veste
à 1652 oh c'est bon là je ne peux pas
pas y'a rien et rien promet premier rang
la facture s'est alourdie guillaume
genton a volé quelque chose
la facture s'est alourdie regarder
le dernier drame date d'il ya quelques
heures cyril et c'est une faute grave
oui il a osé le conte nous avons un
nouveau forcené dans l'équipe
heureusement que votre assistante et
gendarmes savent a été dans le secteur
pour protéger votre patrimoine
artistique monsieur guillon wilfrid
j'entends a osé subtiliser un objet de
valeur dans votre pied-à-terre
professional et l'a mis dans un vulgaire
sac de course cyril roux doit finir
j'entends il n'y a plus qu'une seule
issue ces tissus
[Applaudissements]
je parle de sa vie que
je nie les faits vous devez zoomer sur
les minces et les mains de pernikoff
dans la vienne et à d'autres choses je
peux où je peux m'en aller c'est comme
vous voulez si je me positionne plus
t'as quoi je peux y aller encore sur lui
je peux regarder par la sers toi
[Applaudissements]